so what should we do Gary beep let's
wrap this up which I would do we should
people do people should [ __ ] stop
complaining right people get out on the
[ __ ] they are good call people should
not listen to America propaganda of
fixing the [ __ ] they suck at they should
be tripling down at what they're good at
they should be competent in certain
areas but you're not going to become
Beyonce or you know like your bone
structure is a certain way like you're
not going to solve everything your IQ
can get a little bit better but don't
worry about the incremental figure out
what you [ __ ] put you on fire and
your halfway decent at if you're lucky
enough right now to be listening and
you're good at what you like become
Tunnel [ __ ] vision because there's
way too many voices telling you what and
how and here's the other thing and this
is the big ones up because you have a
humongous audience the biggest thing
that I've seen dividends from have the
conversation with the person that's
holding you back the reason most people
who are listening right now we're not
doing that thing is they're worried
about the opinion of somebody usually
their mother usually their father and
the reality is is that your spouse may
be the person holding you back and you
have to have that conversation cut them
off we have to get to a place where
you're doing you because the number one
thing that scares the [ __ ] out of me is
regret and you're going to sit there at
72 and you say I wish I wish I wish
and whether that's money or spend more
time with your family there's a million
ways to do this not everybody wants to
buy the Jets not everybody wants to
smoke weed on the beach in the Bahamas
like everybody's got a different [ __ ]
thing figure out what your [ __ ] thing
is and stop making [ __ ] [ __ ]
excuses who the president is your mom
did this like like I missed it I had
that idea for uber then why didn't you
[ __ ] do it dick